[Música]
Hola les damos la bienvenida a enlaces
Centroamérica desde San Salvador hoy
haremos un recuento del estado de
excepción medida implementada a petición
de presidente nayib bukele luego de una
escalada de homicidios ocurridos a
finales de marzo y que fueron atribuidos
a las pandillas esta disposición
especial ha sido renovada siete veces y
el gobierno ha señalado que la seguirá
prorrogando hasta ganar la guerra a los
grupos violentos los organismos de la
sociedad civil denuncian constantemente
vulneraciones a los Derechos Humanos
durante este periodo también hablaremos
sobre la decisión del mandatario
salvadoreño de presentarse como
candidato a las elecciones del 2024 algo
inédito en la era democrática del país
acompáñenos
desde que fue aprobado el régimen de
excepción el 28 de marzo se mantienen
suspendidas algunas garantías
constitucionales y han sido capturados
más de 56.000 supuestos pandilleros no
obstante diversos organismos de derechos
humanos han recibido numerosas denuncias
de casos que incluyen detenciones
arbitrarias allanamientos de morada y
malos tratos por parte de agentes
policiales y militares También dan
cuenta de al menos 80 personas que
fueron capturadas y que han muerto en
las cárceles en custodia del estado
y ha venido prorrogándose casi siete
meses vamos por el octavo y no dudamos
que vamos a finalizar el año con un
régimen de excepción y con una
continuidad de estos abusos detenciones
arbitrarias abusos de autoridad personas
que están falleciendo dentro de los
centros de detención sin darles mayor
explicación a la familias y también
criminalizando las Y eso contraviene
distintos Marcos normativos Aunque el
gobierno no reconoce los abusos y las
muertes algunos de sus Voceros han
planteado que en una guerra siempre
habrá víctimas inocentes y daños
colaterales sugiriendo que se debe
extender el régimen hasta que todos los
pandilleros que se calculan en unos
75.000 estén tras las rejas además
justifican la medida sobre lo que
consideran buenos e innegables
resultados dada la disminución de los
homicidios en el país según una reciente
encuesta si bien A medida goza de
popularidad la población rechaza la
vulneración de derechos en los
procedimientos por ejemplo Dos de cada
tres salvadoreños rechaza se realicen
capturas sin una orden del juez o una
investigación previa
afuera de la sede judi
Ciales a diario se observan personas que
acuden con
aspere sean liberados su familiares a
sabiendas de que no es la norma sino la
excepción a Natalia es parte de un grupo
en su mayoría mujeres que esperan que el
juez decrete la libertad para su
familiares ocho menores de edad que
fueron acusados por agrupaciones
ilícitas 7 horas de espera fueron en
vano ninguno fue liberado a Natalia
también regresó sola a casa A pesar que
fue la única que tuvo acompañamiento de
abogados particulares Pues el caso tomó
notoriedad luego que denunciara que su
hija de 17 años sufrió una emergencia
obstétrica que le provocó la pérdida de
su embarazo después de ser golpeada
durante su captura Hace cuatro meses y
medio pues digo una injusticia Porque
mira yo soy la mamá yo la necesito si es
mi hija yo la quiero conmigo verdad eso
de que digan Pues que es un régimen pero
yo pienso que tienen que tener una un
papel para agarrar a la persona que
deben verdad mi hija no debe nada y al
contrario imagina voy a perder el bebé
al centro penitenciario
familiares como el caso de a Natalia
viven en constantes sus obras al no
recibir información sobre el estado de
las personas detenidas esta vez sintió
alivio al ver con sus propios ojos a su
hija pero pudo advertir durante la
audiencia judicial cierto grado de
desnutrición en ella según comentó ya
Naciones Unidas a recomendado garantizar
en los centros de detención que haya
condiciones de legalidad humanidad
dignidad y garantías judiciales además
aunque el gobierno ha proyectado la
construcción de una mega cárcel puede
desencadenarse una crisis humanitaria
debido al aumento de la población
penitenciaria si se suman todos los
capturados durante el régimen la cifra
de reos ya supera las 90.000 personas
cuando la capacidad del sistema
carcelario es para poco más de 30.000 la
desprotección de los niños y las niñas
cuyos padres o familiares encargados han
sido detenido es también un efecto
directo del régimen de excepción los
niños están completamente abandonados
por parte del Estado
solamente digamos con el cuido de su
abuela o de una joven de 18 años que
difícilmente pueden proveer los cuidados
de una madre de una madre o de un padre
que actualmente están capturados por el
régimen de excepción con la popularidad
más a un caudal político con miras a las
elecciones del 2024 de ahí su anuncio a
participar en los comicios pese a la
existencia de prohibiciones
constitucionales dichas trabas fueron
saltadas en septiembre del 2021 cuando
una cuestionada sale de lo
constitucional de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia modificó el criterio de la
reelección continua antes de esta
resolución quien ocupaba la presidencia
debía esperar 10 años después de
concluir su mandato
en la reelección inmediata no es posible
incluso hay presupuestos normativos bien
fuertes que establecen de una u otra
manera que no se puede el que no estén
en la presidencia ni un día más o
incluso el tema de llamar a la
insurrección insurrección común de ver
frente a una posible reelección aferrado
a su política de mano dura buquela se
encamina a ser el primer presidente de
la etapa democrática salvadoreña que
intentará reelegirse dado que esta
situación no se daba desde la época de
la dictadura militar Gracias por
acompañarnos en este enlace
Centroamérica desde San Salvador para
ver nuestros programas síguenos en Flash
24 y France 24.com